I for one and moving on from fake news
there's a new phrase in town a new lingo
with which to familiarize yourself fake
gloss that's what I said
BAE Claus this is not about taking sides
whether you are left-right independent
or agnostic respect for our laws is
essential they are not fake we are a
nation of laws
now senators Kamala Harris Kirsten
Gillibrand Cory Booker ironically all
three eyeing the 2020 presidential run
and the left insistent iced Immigration
and Customs Enforcement be abolished the
call was wrapped up this week when
Harris asserted that ice is perceived as
the modern-day Ku Klux Klan take a look
as she grills Acting Director of ice
rattles vide ello ring are you aware of
the perception of many about how the the
power and the discretion at ice is being
used to enforce the laws and do you see
any parallels I do not see any parallels
between I'm talking about perceptions
and agents I'm talking about perception
I do not see a parallel between what is
constitutionally mandated as it relates
to enforcing the law are you aware that
there's the perceptions we know are you
aware that there's an ice in the same
category as the KKK since when are
carrying out the duties of law
enforcement akin to acting like a
Klansmen since when are men and women to
whom we give badges and guns who uphold
the law and put their lives on the line
considered domestic terrorists since
when do we persecute people for doing
the job the law empowers them to do
perception is one thing but laws passed
by Congress signed by the commander in
chief are reality
irrespective of our like or dislike of a
law no one can choose to ignore the
law the law is meant to be followed and
enforced Kamala you were prosecutor and
attorney general you enforce the law by
prosecuting those who didn't follow it I
doubt you ask the accused about their
perception of the law and I doubt you
even cared in fact when you ran for
Senate you promised to quote combat
transnational gangs working with Mexico
to prevent them from bringing guns and
drugs across our border to fight human
trafficking and to improve public safety
how are you gonna do that without ice
who you gonna call ghostbusters was the
Khan then or is the Khan now as someone
who claims to champion minority
communities you know they are the ones
most impacted by drug cartels and gangs
coming through our porous border between
2017 and 2018 ice seized more than three
hundred and sixty eight thousand pounds
of drugs and made almost 5,000 drug
arrests ice made more than 1,700
arresting gang investigations including
ms-13 members more than 430 criminal
arrests in child exportation
exploitation investigations rescuing
hundreds of child victims and you want
to oppose ice you call them like KKK if
you don't like a law kamala there's a
process to change it and here's the rub
you can change it as a United States
Senator work within the framework of the
exalted position to which you were
elected sponsor a bill get support for
the bill and get it passed
don't chin up people into a frenzy
suggesting Isis like the KKK with images
of burning crosses and lynchings of
innocent African Americans likening it
to innocent Mexicans and
chill Americans you of all people should
understand the anger and hate that that
conjures up as a woman who's half
african-american you of all people
should understand the history and the
role of the KKK played through the
Democrat Party so let me see if I get
this right I should be eliminated
because it scares people people who have
broken our laws to come here many have
already exhibited violence along the way
in Tijuana and Guatemala
mostly men demanding entrance as if
they're entitled to be here what you're
doing is planting seeds of fear
resistance and resentment against ice
among people who have no right to come
here who've already broken our laws to
get here and they're scared people
should be afraid when they violate our
laws the people though who should be
afraid are innocent Americans at risk in
sanctuary cities and states where
illegals who are also criminals are
given safe haven your con puts those
American citizens in jeopardy how about
a little dose of reality Kamala and not
your perception nonsense
take a look at these pictures Kate
Steinle Mali Tibbets
nice and Mickens Kyla Cuevas and the
scores of American citizens killed by
illegals your perception of Isis a KKK
is pure insanity this is America the law
is the law
respected honor it fear it damn it
fear it any questions and that's my open
if you like my opening statements you'll
love my new book new york times number
one bestseller liars leakers and
liberals the case against the anti-trump
conspiracy